bootleg cat podcast
we got a superstar in the building
fresh from Dave's Hot Chicken
Armani Caesar is here what's goody the
list two is out yes it is one of my
favorite sweaters I own is from the
original Liz yes you bought that hoodie
great hoodie uh yo we actually have a
full interview you guys could go run
that [ __ ] up on the other video but
let's get to These Bars man griselda's
in the building yeah
[Music]
shout out my [ __ ] Yak King Combs
without the [ __ ] yo I'm a top flow
[ __ ] young honcho [ __ ] yeah I'm
getting chips and cheese but I'm not
your [ __ ] in my [ __ ] move that weight
that's my Chopper dick Elgato he stay on
his waffle [ __ ] why you don't like me
cause a Man flying I see your [ __ ]
dumped you when he made me wifey please
my mouth crazy I made the fight and he
told a [ __ ] you hate me but your baby
like me real [ __ ] only no dogs or
Barbies birth a new culture like satin
McCarty y'all sorry lost and tardy I'm
like fortnite and got hoes Atari huh I
ain't got haters [ __ ] I got fans you
[ __ ] got beef [ __ ] I got bands Y'all
[ __ ] mad pill my [ __ ] got tens
check this network boy I got plans what
big sauce big pie big drip big watch a
[ __ ] mad a [ __ ] nah we twins [ __ ]
stop when I take a pic the [ __ ] turned
out of mean I sit floor seats they put
me on the screen only major league with
money you want to see him looking like I
hit a home run not a Field of Dreams
what I never even asked him if you got a
[ __ ] the bag right we could do all kind
of [ __ ] the [ __ ] good so I talk a lot
of [ __ ] I never gave a [ __ ] about no
promises oh [ __ ] Walling wallet oh she
bang bang my [ __ ] gang gang it's a
pretty dang thing talking to town [ __ ]
that drip you drowning made him say [ __ ]
the phone give me your brown skin
the list two out right now ladies and
gentlemen Armani Caesar in the building
Let's Get It Go
that was fire thank you hey you just
watched a crazy freestyle and we dropped
one every week sometimes more than once
a week and they're always presented by
our family at LRG now I love LRG I'm
wearing look I'm gonna just show you the
new shorts I got from them check out
them shorts my boy you know what I'm
saying and got the plain black tea the
plain black lrgt you know what I mean
listen lrg's back they just dropped the
crazy Jason hoodie with Jadakiss that's
from like 2008 for Halloween [ __ ]
Flames go to the website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you 30 off when you use
the promo code bootleg 30 percent off
that's a significant amount of money
you're going to be saving when you go to
lrg's website Christmas is coming save
30 off just by going to the website and
using the promo code bootleg L Dash R
g.com we'll see you next week with a
crazy freestyle